le gouvernement n'a pas adapté notre
pays à cette deuxième vague pendant des
mois rien n'a été fait selon vous de
l'image avril rien n'aurait été fait
rage à la dérive la preuve demandé au
médecin légiste et le prix d'un public
hier lundi on a retenu les leçons
les gars sont selon-vous bas j'en sais
rien quelle leçon le système de santé
n'a pas bougé il est ok au contraire il
est encore beaucoup plus déstabilisé
qu'au mois de mars le seul outil que ce
gouvernement fait fonctionner ses
ouvertures fermetures aucune vision vous
croyez pas que toute cette période
aurait pu être mise à profit comme l'ont
fait d'autres pays pour augmenter le
nombre de lits de réanimation pour
pouvoir former du personnel recruté du
personnel notamment les personnels de
santé qui aujourd'hui épuisée exemple
les personnels de santé ont fait des
propositions tous les médecins qui ils
sont vieux philippe juvin qui chef des
urgences de pompidou il avait fait des
propositions notamment pour réorganiser
les services pour qu'il y ait moins de
strates administratives pour que la
décision soit beaucoup plus près du
terrain beaucoup plus près du soin -
d'administratifs plus de soin plus de
santé ils ont fait le corps médical a
fait des propositions ils n'ont pas été
entendus
ils n'ont pas été suivis de la même
manière les acteurs économiques
il découvre hier soir qu il y aura un
couvre feu
je pense aux restaurateurs aux bains aux
acteurs de la culture qui depuis des
mois s'adapte propose faire mes yeux les
amortisseurs 0 marino visuel le chômage
partiel appelant réactivé pour tous les
secteurs de la restauration et aux deux
nouveaux délais pour les prêts garantis
par l'état à ce que c'est à l'abri des
catastrophes annoncées mais un trait
garantie quand vous l'avez plus de
clients quand vous n'avez plus
l'activité
le prêt ça se rembourse à un moment
donné donc certains ne veulent même plus
prendre le risque de prendre des prêts
parce qu'il n'y a plus d'activité
économique les acteurs économiques les
acteurs de la culture sont totalement
abandonnés à leur sort
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous devons
être aux côtés des salariés des
entreprises et dirigeants d'entreprises
qui nous permette que ce pays que la
france le s'effondre on ne vous a pas
échappé qu'aujourd'hui l'impunité totale
des délinquants s'est installé dans
notre pays face à l'autorité aujourd'hui
les forces de l'ordre les forces de
sécurité l'autorité plus globalement que
ce soit les élus
alors comment un couvre-feu à 21h dans
certains quartiers dans certains
territoires où les policiers paris
nantes et même pas comment ça va être
policier les policiers eux mêmes disent
qu'ils sont déjà épuisés et débordés par
eux la délinquance du quotidien et donc
va s'ajouter à eux cette nouvelle
mission de devoir contrôler ce
couvre-feu l'impunité s'est installée
aujourd'hui il faut des réponses claires
et fermes et c'est bien ce que l inverse
il y aurait des consignes aux jo les
policiers n'interviennent pas vous pas
aujourd'hui les policiers bat en
retraite quand ils sont attaqués vous
avez remarqué
il bat en retraite pourquoi eux ils les
policiers ont plus peur d'être mise en
cause
ils ont peur de leur mise en cause alors
que les voyous en toute impunité
ils savent très bien un qui ne vont pas
être mis en cause d'eux qu'ils ne vont
pas être incarcéré ni interpellé est
donc évidemment l'impunité totale s'est
installée aujourd'hui il faut renverser
cet ordre là et l'ordre doit revenir
force doit rester à la loi et la police
doit pouvoir riposter quand ils sont
attaqués et ça crée ça c'est une
politique de sécurité à assumer et à
annoncer je peux vous dire que c'est
extrêmement dissuasif
il faut rétablir les peines planchers et
notamment avec une peine minimale à
l'encontre de ceux qui s'accouplent qui
s'attaquent non seulement forces de
sécurité mais à toute personne
représentant l'autorité